you
okay here we go three check tournament
27 players turned out for this one
one minute mm-hmm
let us see white certainly has an
advantage here give me the D file okay I
won just one it's happening king e7
Queen d6 and I could pick my favorite
way to deliver a third check the e5
Bishop f4 up d1 yeah he's sacked just
open up that D file back to tournament
land whoo I went up a good chunk of
points there already
oh I did say that we can definitely get
in a lot of games with Street check
these games could end quick second light
in a row I like it
Knights are more valuable than bishops
it's my feeling
d4 wouldn't have been good because of
Bishop b4 check alright they have one
check be very careful let's take that
night out that was close to an Elmer
Fudd right there huh watch out for Elmer
Fudd d5 Knight here maybe I get the
e-file rook checks gotta play 97 right
this is deadly let's pin the night
here probably wasn't a good idea well I
don't know should be alright they don't
have much time 1 minute 3 check
tournament you really got to fly you'll
have to know what you're doing
alright usually it's the kind of want to
keep that King ruck closer to the king
like the Queen rook here better because
now I take this rook and its width check
and I could take with another check and
I only need one more I have the square
covered with my knight but just to be
safe
who determine they could have captured
my knight and then looked forward to a
Rick move so if they took my knight they
ran out of time but if they took my
knight I think I need you to play king
h2 oh well yeah that early Bishop takes
f2 really isn't enough all right Derrick
oh this is our first time playing
I was already moved by D pawn and that
was my advice before the tournament
careful about moving your D pawn in
three check ok knight c6 ok let's go
here you can give me a full
just to lend a check I don't think that
that's a good idea I think I should be
alright with preventing two checks
paying up a full piece we're going to
find out
ah huh I got a check back really tempted
to take that fish up let's give it a
shot I only need one more check I've got
two tricky nights around one of them
we'll do it one of them will do it it's
happening you have to give up the Queen
now yeah cuz my other night could have
played here and then I had Knights III
can't block a night check let's just
castle Lord just give me that was mate
back to tournament their check I got
eight four four eight and a bunch of
fours a couple twos alright ooh-ho Vic
is in there right out of nowhere let's
go with e4 if we play three check before
Popovic hmm already gonna call pawn
hunting no it should be four and then
Bishop takes II thought maybe um let's
just hang on to the light square Bishop
give him a kick and then get back here
here we go Castle I push here and then
smashing at h7
Space Invader can't move that deep on I
don't think at least there should be
five will be deadly alrighty I'm just
going to line some pieces up here
alright I'd like to see this file open
up hmm they invested a pawn for what
reason exactly we're going to find out
that would have once a material move
forward first already
they don't have much time they're going
to take on si - lets just stop rip take
situ and scoop this up next let's go
here need a flight square going take
spawn next what's that about
they just blundered back determine
twelve eight eight eight a lot of time
left in this one who thirty six players
are now in it
nice Lyman twenty-seven all right let's
go with the Sicilian I think the Conn
the Sicilian conned set up these moves
here are good on the black end against
efore and three Czech knight c6 into d4
is also a threatening move to white
because you're ready to take with check
um okay yeah let's go in for this right
now
Wow all right let's take with the Queen
and I think I want to do this next are
they considering
this just to get an open E file or maybe
even just to get a rook here I'm going
to do this to make it a little bit
difficult for the bishop to get working
and just continue developing really
don't care about the loss of a pond fish
up here maybe I should have done this
sooner Bishop takes f2 is certainly a
threat with Queen d4 and Queen f2 was
the follow up well even still this
Knight takes pawn with check it's got to
be good I don't have any time I take c4
Knight g3 um anything no checks going
takes our queen d3 check Oh for a second
I thought that that was hitting with
check back determinants are down on time
1616 1210 John Madden
he had a speed bump in game 1 and if
you're gonna have a speed bump that's
the one that game 1 is the one to lose
ok let us see let's continue with this
hmm fishing pole ideas can be quite
interesting hmm
alright let's start with this Knight d4
let's go here guard these squares I want
to see the H file open up definitely
make it happen let's take here what's
wrong with that and then stop Bishop
takes Knight with Czech Queen here is
maybe already starting to be an idea I
don't want to Castle King here let's
definitely go here off of this diagonal
off of the file with Chuck and now we're
threatening
devastation Knight takes Knight with
Czech Queen h2 this might just be a good
move in regular chess
yeah this is collapsing no Knights are
swarming he's pretty much immune on g4
otherwise you have to deal with Brooke
sacrifices um okay let's just take a
timeout for this now we have these
checks with also queen h2 stuff
let's take gonna take the bishop rook up
now here and
of g3 that's one I should be able to get
all three now two and three you'll do it
back determine 2016 12 12 10 20 minutes
to go all right
okay I am on fire the chest prince is in
there nice and we are paired up
all right chess Prince the French ah
they juked me there you know I may be
this this is something is this a is this
a good idea this night's a creation tell
you what I'm going to do I'm going to go
straight in for that and throw another
piece in there that's one check oh boy
oh boy
I get the piece back I'm going to have a
tough time castling oh oh they're caught
in the middle I got the Queen they don't
have any checks against me
oh they're going to block with the
bishop okay noted I see whoa it's very
weakening let's go alright bishop no
rook up and over all right we're looking
for
two more checks are going to play f6 hmm
don't like how I'm playing this oh
they're going to take the rook oh I
could take you with check though hmm
all right let's take once I need to keep
some material on if that rook moves I
have Queen b8 same story if the rook
moves I should have done this to threat
now because I could get to c7 as well
maybe the King comes up to the seventh
rank hmm let's go here rook moves I have
Queen d5
okay let's encourage that oh now they
could play rook here Queen takes b7 keep
marching
ah I totally missed that
oh man Prince I totally missed that and
that was um that was h2o Queen h2 I did
not see that rook coming over to H the H
file mm man okay we're tied 2020 I did
not see that that was that one stunned
me man okay yeah I think that that line
is interesting isn't it I think so that
sack of the knight on c3 oh alright they
have a check in there they were
threatening Queen takes pawn and then
Bishop c3 I'm gonna play Bishop here
right now alright this must be good now
Knight takes c2 and then Queen takes f2
yeah this is
busted now mmm that was a really close
game against the Prince there in the
think tank on this one um I could check
here and then go here for me got it back
to tournament 24 whoo he has fire - he's
in first 24 22 24 petrol check is in
there
funny name for three check there will be
no perpetual check in three check and
I'm playing against the Prince again
might we revisit this same line we're
gonna find out I'm an experiment with it
why not
ooh supposed to take first want to go in
for this now this is serious isn't that
I want to crash through on this um let's
go here and what next
okay so they're just given the material
back I want a rook up and over okay
they're really crawling up into a ball
some hmm yeah there bishop is a is
really glued in there let's try to
undermine that bishops position
immediately all right let's target b7
maybe I get a past beep on do have it I
think I think I want to hang on to that
seat pun oh they're trying something on
h2 again are you kidding me amazing I
don't think it's working out this time
but whoa um let's go here
Oh No
the stories with that move stunned me
certainly stunned me um wow wow I I not
only have three seconds what is with
this targeting of the H pond why are you
doing this to me
I have any time either oh they could
take here now oh my goodness
unbelievable I'm down on time and I just
gonna resign anyway
wow man these rook lifts to get me with
the H file stuff man I gotta get the
Prince back
28:22 that's too goose eggs
alright half-baked taco I gotta get some
quick wins in here do not touch that
deep on let's stop Bishop takes here for
sure not good to play d5 because of
Bishop b5 let's get here Bishop b5 I
have to do this alright
Queen e7 and how about we push might be
5 I drop back alright let's open this up
it's Castle Rock on a to e8 get on this
dog
be nice night here Knight takes d5 I
don't know I'll go here
it takes d5 maybe Knight takes f2 I
don't know it's messy and by messy I
mean probably not good
okay take with this pawn don't want to
allow Bishop c4
alright now you see this is what you
have to do you have to target h2 that's
all you have to do
they got one check but there should be
well its mate by regular means I love
those 32 24 24 he's got an eight-point
lead no speed bumps would we get paired
up again would it even help if I end up
beating him if we get paired up again
alright efore I don't know why I keep
trying to play Knight f3 and move one in
these three checks the Carroll huh well
that's different
alrighty I could win upon let's give him
a boot space oh just Castle 92 let's
shift over towards the Kings side there
we go
and maybe this Knight takes f7 let's do
it yeah it's got to be good mmm let's go
here
f4 f5 I don't have c5 because of Bishop
b5 they went with it and yeah that's
going to do it it's got to be a win by
force now sacking the queen there's
another check and they resigned
I think they resigned alright
36 move he just remains on fire 36 26
and he's in the game go John Madden come
on John Madden get him get him John
Madden
I'm not paired up yet look at this
John Madden hit him with Queen takes h2o
I wonder how many checks he has let's
check it out he has two you only need
one more John Madden ah you're getting
made on the dark squares though why am I
not getting paired up ah he tried it he
tried getting at that h2 square the
prince again this is the one this is the
one I got to get this one here alright
let's see what he throws at me when he's
playing the what the white piece is
really you do that okay interesting
that's Castle Oh No I'm going to take
their there they really know to target
those uh the kingside squares huh
already hmm don't like how I'm playing
this he's returning there isn't he oh
they're going to do a rook lift and I'm
dead I can't move I need to get here
it's important I have my knight on this
square alright I'm going to be giving up
some material kind of focus on these
dark squares hmm okay let's just do this
cannot allow
takes their they're eating some time
eating some clock a lot of time is being
wasted here hmm okay on the night I'm on
b2 Wow can I do that defend like this
hmm
now I'll dawn time big time
um oh they have a queen check I have
that and I don't have enough pieces oh
I'm done
ah man toasted like I smashed me again
three times in a row the prince mmm man
he had a lot of pressure on me
forty-four squeaky clean performance
forty-four I have 27 27 shooting for
second at this point Wow Bishop d3
castle
II five I think I could have used an
opening adjustment in that game my
light-square bishop was a big dummy not
really contributing and theirs was a
monster on d3 okay Queenie to e5 maybe I
go Queen side hmm
I'll be interested to investigate the
the white games that I played against
him with that Knight sac on c3 allowing
the opening up of the D file let's crack
this open black king is in the center
and now we're going to be able to take
here with check that's one Queen blocks
I have Queen B 5 and if King to d8 I
would have Queenie 7 check for a second
44 3
30:28 okay let's go at c5 stop Bishop
takes f7 for sure all right I think I
might try this fishing pole stuff again
okay let's see yeah this might be deadly
let's see I could afford Queen takes f7
Bishop takes e6 I believe hmm let's go
here
targeting f2 hmm Bishop takes Bishop is
losing because of Queen takes f7
interesting let's drop back because
Queen takes f7 and then pawn takes and
the rook is hitting I think I need to
castle take with the rook on Queen takes
f7 let's go here and I think I need to
go here Queen e5 keep the dark squares
controlled I could have maybe picked up
the H pawn the Queen goes too far I have
g3 okay they drop the night Queen here
whit's check that's one um let's go here
threatening Queen g3 and Bishop here or
h4 would you just move man you have any
time that Bishop d7 is maybe not a bad
move actually okay now we got this
we definitely have this now think tank
can't stop at Queen check next no way
one right here right there it's 1 2 h2
4835 30 John man has a 5 point lead
who
ooh man anybody gonna catch me maybe
this guy catch me although he doesn't
have fire the perpetual check is playing
against the chest prints right now
alright
Sicilian land let's go knight c6 stop
Bishop f7 let's still go with this lady
for threatening the bishop right now and
let's go here get on this diagonal
alright
are they going to miss it
they might know I could take here
actually Knight takes h2 with h4 and the
H file is opening up now due to the pin
there is no g4 double check only counts
for one check yeah this is getting
ripped apart now on takes rook h1 stuff
and that's going to do it here and then
there no matter what
oh oh okay I thought they were going to
let the clock tick back to terminate 52
35 34 John Madden slipped up less than
three can I sneak in to second place
we're going to find out should be four
block alright they lost a lot of time
right there five let's get him out of
there yeah if I can
and then plate h3 they would have h5 so
let's do this first get him out of there
and take I don't know let's go Queen
side and h1 Knight to g5 I think I like
two minutes left in the tournament
they're really tuned on this one let's
take him out and I don't know let's go
here right here next I don't think that
that's a worthwhile check I don't know
that that's a good investment give up a
full piece like that hmm let's take here
there's only one Queen check Bishop
checks rook checks they have two but
they're not going to get a third that's
one let's just go here well I should
have just waited for a moment still
winning but Queen f3 would have been
better back to tournament 52-38 I have a
lead a tie-break wise over John Madden
3838 can I get one more game in they
going to pair me up it's only a minute
to the tournament all right let's see 55
seconds because John Madden's in the
middle of the game right now
okay let's not move the deep on 45
seconds 42 seconds
it's Castle now we could look at this
okay with tempo got a fork winning
material of the e4 square let me to take
the
with check only 22 seconds John Madden
one I got to get this there's 19 seconds
okay wait I should've taken the bishop
sooner it's a check I got one check in
there
seven seconds I'm not going to allow
that there's only a second left they hit
me on each - OH
okay let's just try to win this one huh
I have this square covered this rook up
and over stuff man I tell you it's
dangerous
these rook lifts are very dangerous in
three check there we go that's a third
back to tournament land whoo very strong
performance here by the chest prince who
went squeaky-clean 56 and of course ends
up on fire 56:41 for john madden 38 for
me morning coffee 32 perpetual check 32
vas fed my most frequent opponent in
this variant in there with 30 trap king
pelvic PACs yo 700 right and in the end
there were 43 in this one already to the
43 of you that took part in what is
probably my favorite variant 3 check
good games all already
you